getting crank called on one hour's sleep  three four five in the morning that  exposes who you actually are you're  calling around senator tell him sam how  many doctors  yes i need to speak to guest uh his name  is gary vaynerchuk and i can spell that  for you it's v a y v-a-y-n-e-r-c-h-u-k  what was the first name uh the first  name is gary with the g right yes please  thank you  hello  yes is this gary this is gary gary hello  my name is tom crush and you're  destroying my life i'm sorry tom crush  everyone keeps telling me to crush  things some man actually physically  crushed me i'm sorry buddy what should i  do you should tell them to crush off  what what is crush it and why does  everyone want to do it to me i'm not  sure why they want to crush you bro but  tom crush is an amazing name to have bro  i thought so too i don't it's almost  like a superhero i agree all right sorry  bro thank you for your help gary bye-bye